In 536 A.D., there was a worldwide dust cloud
that blocked out the sun for a year, resulting
in widespread famine and disease.
The most common reaction from men confronted
by TV Licensing Enforcement Officers is, 'I
thought my wife was dealing with it.'
A kilogramme of houseflies contains more protein
than a kilogramme of beef.
Despite popular belief, studies show men are
not more flatulent than women.
The acnestis is the part of the back that
is impossible to scratch.
After George W. Bush was re-elected president
in 2004, the number of calls from US citizens
to the Canadian Immigration authorities jumped
from 20,000 to 115,000 a day.
Thomas Edison proposed to his second wife
in Morse code.
Until 1857, it was legal for British husbands
to sell their wives.
The going rate was £3,000 or £23,000 in
today's money.
Some species of scorpion survive on just one
meal a year.
In space you cannot cry because there is no
gravity to make the tears flow.
Australia has 10 times more camels than koalas.
In 1987, American Airlines saved $40,000 by
removing an olive from each salad in First
Class.
The statue of Winston Churchill in Parliament
Square is electrified to stop pigeons perching
on its head.
Bill Clinton was mauled by a sheep at the
age of eight and didn't learn to ride a bicycle
till he was 22.
To protect its public image Google own hundreds
of other domains including googlepoo.com and
googlesucks.com.
Victorian guidebooks advised women to put
pins in their mouths to avoid being kissed
in the dark when trains went through tunnels.